hi
and welcome to the future of application
development with cloud databases
my name is minh and i am a product
manager for cloud firestore
join with me today is nathan a software
engineer from dot
today's session will be focused on
resolving
one key question
why is it so challenging to build and
scale applications
and more importantly what is google
doing to make application development
easier
to answer this question we'll begin by
reviewing two popular application
architectures
choosing an architecture has a large
impact on how an application is built
and how it scales
in the second part of the session you'll
hear a customer testimonial from dot
describing how thoughtful architectural
decisions have impacted their business
finally we'll round out the session with
new product announcements and resources
to learn more about firestar
let's get started
imagine for a moment that you're writing
a new application
and decide to use a more traditional
interior architecture
today's example can apply to any general
purpose application but to ground the
discussion let's assume it's an
e-commerce app
at the heart of the application is a
database
the database is used to store data
in front of the database are typically a
set of microservices that manage your
application's business logic
let's assume that you have three
separate microservices a service for
your product catalog
a service for your product inventory and
lastly a service for your shopping carts
as usage for your microservices grow and
declines you'll need a load balance
traffic while horizontally scaling and
compacting capacity
in order to secure access to these
microservices you'll need to add an api
gateway
finally to enable broad distribution of
your application you'll need to develop
clients the web
android and even ios
furthermore if you want to make sure
that your users always have the latest
data can access your application when
they're offline you'll need to add
support for web sockets and an offline
caching system
as you can see there's a lot of
technical complexity here
unfortunately
technical complexity can be the enemy of
business innovation
let's examine the downstream impact this
architecture has
first
operationalizing all the services that
support an application can be intensive
second
each layer of the architecture typically
represents specialized teams
which means complex dependency planning
and therefore potential risks for
project delay
third sourcing talent for each layer of
the architecture can be difficult and
expensive
especially in competitive hiring markets
like
today
let's figure out how google was solving
for each of these challenges starting
with the operational challenge
google offers management services for
each layer of the stack
with cloud sql for example we will
assist you in operationalizing popular
relational databases such as postgresql
mysql or even microsoft sql
with kubernetes engine we will assist
you in operationalizing your
microservices
with apogee we will assist you in
operationalizing your api gateway
so the combination of these management
services from google will assist you in
operationalizing each layer of the stack
while still enabling high customization
alternatively if you're interested in
taking the serverless route
you can use cloudrun to run your
microservices
in firestore as your database
choosing to go the serverless route
allows you to delegate operational
complexity to google
freeing up your team to focus on product
development
okay
we've addressed operational complexity
but what about projects or hiring
complexity
let's examine how a deeper investment in
firestore can address the remaining
challenges
firestore is a serverless document
database that can also act as a complete
backend as a service
firebase auth is a service that allows
you to delegate your applications off
and user management to google
firestore and firebase auth are
seamlessly integrated using the
combination of these two services allows
customers to focus on ui development
delegating secure off and back in
service management to google
furthermore you'll get built-in
functionality for real-time
synchronization
connection management between clients
and your database
and offline caching using the firestore
sdks
so by using firestore as a backend as a
service you can focus on ui development
and ui teams are empowered to make
decisions
as they no longer are dependent on
changes from back end teams
with universal application frameworks
like google flutter or facebook react
you can now write native applications
using the single code base and deploy
them across multiple client platforms
such as the web
android and ios
firestore
fully supports these universal app
frameworks with an easy to use set of
plain sdks
as a result with firestore and universal
app frameworks you can focus on hiring
for flutter or react skills from a very
large poll of developers
the result of these investments enables
you to focus on business innovation
through a single
autonomous team and code base
there are many factors that go into
application development
net google we're investing in a complete
ecosystem for app development
this includes
one
core ui frameworks and operating systems
to build applications
two
in-app services from firebase to manage
aspects like auth
and three
back-end services from google cloud to
manage aspects like back office
analytics using bigquery
firestore brings together these
portfolio investments in an intelligent
way by enabling seamless integration
into each of these portfolios
frequently
applications rely on third-party
services and it's important that these
services are also seamlessly integrated
with firestore
one popular integration request we've
received has been an integration with
elastic
today
we're excited to announce in partnership
with elastic a new extension that
streams changes from a firestore
database to an elastic app search
instance
you can install this extension and many
other third-party extensions from the
firebase extensions directory
so in summary firestore allows customers
to focus on business value and product
differentiation you would document
database that can also act as a back-end
as a service
with over 250 000 monthly active
developers you can have confidence
that's the solution is backed by a large
community of developers
furthermore with firestore applications
now supporting 750 million monthly
active end users using firebase auth you
can be confident that firestore will
scale to your business's needs
we've covered the traditional ntier and
firestorm architectures
let's review the strengths of each
the traditional entire offers high
customizability is compatible with
popular open source frameworks and
libraries
however
as we explained in this session this
normally comes at the trade-off of
technical
project and hiring complexity
pricing for this solution is often
driven by a capacity model which means
that you have to configure how capacity
is scaled
and your build for capacity even when
it's not fully utilized
firestore on the other hand provides a
fully integrated google-based solution
that significantly reduces technical
operational
project and hiring complexity
customers who choose firestore have the
flexibility to use it as a back-end as a
service
in an interior architecture
or maybe a hybrid of the bow
since it's serverless pricing for
firestore is based on actual operations
conducted
storage used for network egress
and with that
i'm excited to introduce nathan from dot
who will share how dot uses firestar
[Music]
good morning
i'm nathan
one of the engineers who joined dot at
the very beginning of our journey
we are a micro mobility operator with
over 50 000 e-scooters and e-bikes
across 35 cities in europe
we are active in nine countries
in capitals like london paris and warsaw
and many more cities
i have been fortunate to participate in
growing our company from the very first
scooter to tens of thousands we operate
today to see our engineering
organization expand to over 30 people
looking forward to welcoming many more
before the year's end
to enable millions to take clean rides
at dot we deeply care about the
environment
and we try to reduce our carbon
footprint as much as possible
while google cloud is carbon neutral
it's even better not to consume any kind
of resources in the first place
that's why we choose technologies which
rapidly up and down scale to precisely
match our needs
firestore is one of these technologies
it has been a core to our solutions from
the very beginning
we started on firestore by connecting
our vehicles
which frequently send information about
their location and relevant telemetry
we quickly moved to user-facing features
using firestore as a backhand
connecting to it directly from our apps
allowed us to work efficiently and
independently
we were a small team back then
removing the need for any back-end
development allowed us to ship features
quickly
in a single day
with real-time synchronization
we were able to implement a vibrant live
map of available scooters
over time we added many functionalities
from basic ones like starting and ending
a trip
to more complex
such as payments processing where
accuracy is critical
for these functionalities firestore
provided us not only with an ability to
develop rapidly
but with an ability to develop with
confidence
allowing us to ensure correctness with
the use of transactions
the world changes all the time so does
our business
more sophisticated functionalities
require specialized services
we have developed a lot of these
and each time firestore has proven to be
a good fit
some of these services replaced
directories from our apps
when we needed complexity that was
easier to manage with a dedicated
backhand
but we are grateful we didn't have to
implement all of svs back in the days
when there were just a few of us
some of the recent changes we all
experienced were challenging for
individuals and businesses alike
shelter in place orders while necessary
affected every one of us
and affected a lot of companies
including dot
our choice to utilize firestore and our
serverless products
helped us navigate shelter in place
with the lower usage came a lower bill
with the expected one-to-one correlation
nowadays mandating more towards
individual transportation
such as with the use of e-scooters and
e-bikes
due to health safety reasons
at dot we see many more riders and trips
in comparison to pre-copied numbers
with utilization of our fleet 75 higher
in some cities
such as brussels
scalability of firestore enabled us to
support this demand without requiring
any changes on our site
as regards our infrastructure
we simply don't have to worry what
happens next
firestore will adapt to our needs and
support us in our journey
now that you know a bit more about our
history
it's a good time to share with you what
i think about it in retrospect
while at the beginning we were
considering other databases
relational graph and document oriented
today i know
but we couldn't have made a better
choice than firestorm
that's why it's such a pleasure for me
to be here today and give this
testimonial
thank you all
and thank you the firestore team
back to you mean
thank you nathan for sharing dot's
journey
i'm excited about dot's impact on the
future of transportation we appreciate
the opportunity to partner with doc
next i'll be sharing exciting product
announcements for firestorm
firestore is committed to the security
and privacy of our customers
to demonstrate that commitment i'm
excited to announce four new features
with data access audit logs
privileged administrators will be able
to audit all operations conducted on a
database with custom iam
customers will be able to align
firestorm permissions to their
organization's iam roles
you can get started with data access
audit logs and custom iam today
with vpc service controls customers will
be able to reduce exfiltration risk
using network level security controls
and without check customers will be able
to ensure only signed and pre-authorized
client applications are allowed to make
requests to firestore
both the previews of vpc service
controls and app track will be rolling
out in q4
firestore's developer experience truly
sets it apart and we are continually
investing in this area
with key visualizer customers will be
able to quickly identify performance
issues with a visual performance
profiler
with the latest version of our web sdk
we have added tree shaking which enables
the reduction of the sdk footprint by as
much as 80
that means faster limit times for your
application
both key visualizer and the new web sdk
are generally available today
we'll also be graduating the unity and c
plus sdks to general availability in q4
both of these sdks are focused on making
it easier to develop mobile games using
wirestore
lastly i'm excited to announce the
graduation of cloud functions triggering
to general availability
cloud functions triggering enables
customers to execute custom business
logic in response to changes to a
firestore document
the session is coming to an end but i
hope this was just the beginning of a
shared journey
if you want to take a moment to try
fireswirl for yourself you can take a
peek at our quick start guides
youtube learning series
and quick labs
if you have additional questions about
using firestore we encourage you to post
those questions on stack overflow
my name was min and i hope that you
enjoyed today's session
if you did please take a moment to fill
out the follow-up survey
bye for now